hello didn't see that I think it was
great face hello today I'm talking with
my friend James we did undergrad
together in physics that was in New
Zealand and now we're both PhD students
together again we wanted to talk about
some physics degree horror stories
because we have plenty of those there
are so many I guess maybe as a deterrent
for anyone who's too optimistic about
studying physics we don't want to put
you off but here are some of the things
that stand out to us as maybe the less
great experience in studying for
studying physics okay first of all one
that I think comes as a shared
experience is the math 240 cause that
was terrible course so math 240 was half
of it was real analysis and half of it
was group Theory I actually liked the
group Theory half of the course but the
real analysis Harper's torture
I think the group Theory saved us yeah
it had been in there failed yes it was
my first experience with pure maths
really and it was in the second year and
I really didn't know what I was getting
myself into
specifically they advertised that course
as for third years to take to do an
extra second year course because it is
the most difficult second year math
course yes so I think this became a
horror story after the midterm test
which was given to us by the lecture who
was this real there's a really good
mathematician but he was very scary
he was the stereotypical
Old English Scottish discarded race
definitely Scottish Scottish direct
mathematician very rigorous rigorous yes
there's something about about it so he
made the test multiple choice which I
thought were great how could you do that
on model choice test excited go wrong
except every wrong answer lost you mugs
and it was basically a guessing game
because it was so so difficult so so
basically if you were to get fifty
percent of the questions right and leave
the rest of the test blank you would get
a passing mark however if you got fifty
percent of the questions right and fifty
percent of the questions wrong you would
get a zero so I came out of the exam
with a glorious minus five and I some
how many just go through with the four
out of a hundred yes that's that's
percentage so that was horrific for me
and I was like oh this is not going well
like I said I think we saved ourselves
with the group theory half but the
feelings after that and getting a
negative score were not good no it was
something that really just crushes you
inside you can't maintain the course
like that
yeah happens oh we got through it in the
end yeah to give you an idea of what the
questions were sort of like there would
basically be a mathematics feel that
would say there is a limit such and such
and such which one of these is the
correct proof sore like a miniature one
like proof and then it would just be a
long line of about 15 to 30 characters
of pure mathematical notation the only
difference between the four answers
would be like some signs will be flipped
or instead of an a character here or be
the e character meaning everything
instead of all
and it came to a point where you
couldn't even read the answers so
sometimes you were just like maybe it's
this one
yeah alright so what about other horror
stories I think a shared one was Steve
Steve the glorious gift Lisa yes I think
this was also the start of second year
there was a first second year physics
course and it was like waves and optics
or something I remember this one in very
well I think you remember I know I was
worried for not six and that we had this
guest lecturer so it was our first week
of second year our first set of homework
per second year on waves and optics one
of the first physics courses we had just
come out of first year which was
considered a little bit harder than high
school math so we were expecting a jump
to second year but we won't know how big
this jump would be now we had a gift
lecture from America called Steve and
apparently he didn't understand what
level we're at maybe you didn't
understand that we were seeking years
maybe you didn't know what they were
seeking years was supposed to be so he
gave us a sheet of homework sheet of
homework that took many hours and made
no progress with many tears I think I
eventually just gave up on the homework
and was like it's kind of too hot I'll
just wait you'll see what the answers
are there it was you persevered maybe I
persevered for a little bit but just
made no progress at all the person who
actually found the answer was our friend
Jordan who was a direct interview to
seeking it so he had never done
university physics at all
this was his very first introduction to
university homework and he was
absolutely terrorized by this but
somehow through I think he said like
five hours of frantic googling and
learning how to do stuff he managed to
get the answer
now the answer itself I can't exactly
remember but I know that it involved a
transformation from normal Cartesian
coordinates into polar coordinates which
to say a third-year math student that
doesn't sound that difficult but when
you're a new second-year student who's
never done a coordinate transformation
inside an already difficult problem it
becomes almost impossible yeah I think
just we just didn't know what we were
supposed to do and I think the whole
class sort of had this feeling we
arrived the next day at the lecture
we're like oh my god
it eventually transpired however that
Steve had given us a problem that was
from a graduate level American grad
school textbook and so I think he was
told like oh you should not have given
them a graduate level problem yeah so
when the original lecture ahead of the
course john paul wells came out and had
a look at the problem he immediately
likely said no there's no way you're
expected to do he laughed at us so that
was fun yeah yeah one more course I
remember was PDAs
partial differential equations for me I
think this was particularly traumatic I
think you it did better in the infant I
did but um it was just bad from start to
finish because I remember I did a
midterm test there were two mid tendus
the first one I got 50% on and I was
like oh my god that's so bad and I made
it my goal to for the second one do a
lot better and make up for that session
and on the second one I also got 50 as I
owned those so she walked out of that
second midterm test walked straight to
the admin Department for the Uni and I
said I'd like to withdraw from a course
please and they were like are sorry the
last stated withdrawal was yesterday
for that I was okay in the end I think
scaling was the miracle that saved me so
I think everyone kind of did as bad as
each other so all of us got lifted and
our grade actually came up with an okay
grade in that course so it was fine in
the end
yep so my last story comes from OTAs
which is ordinary differential equations
the course previous to PBS and in this
one I got to one of the exam questions
and I realized I have no idea how to
answer this there's something I knew a
week ago but I've just suddenly
forgotten I had no idea how to come to
the right answer if I came to the right
answer I could give a good write-up for
what I would how I would actually do the
process I just don't remember the
process so in my brilliant wisdom what I
decided to do is just verbal diarrhea
and write down everything I knew about
that question topic over about three
pages listing if this was the answer
here's what I would do but if it was
this case I would do this instead and if
it was this case they know do this as
well and I just wrote down everything
and I have no idea what mark I got for
that question I did not look at the test
but same with that one I got a pretty
good mark in that course due to the
power of scale due to everyone doing
pretty bad the Praxis scaling I think
that saved us a few times yes I think
those those are some of our main horror
stories there were good times as well
but yet studying physics can definitely
be stressful at times there were lots of
all-nighters as well and just yeah
freaking out over handing in assignments
assignments exams yes yeah everything
labs even
all right thanks James Thank You Norris
and thanks so much